so when's the party Saturday and you're
kind of not invited Gossip Girl turns
ten on September 19 and Leighton Meester
took a trip down memory lane when et
caught up with her and husband Adam
Brody exclusively this summer the ten
year anniversary of Gossip Girls in
September your favorite flare moment I
don't know there are a lot um I mean I
don't know I think like it was a very
there were so many awesome locations I
mean I personally just had like amazing
time shooting in New York click on the
streets spotted on the steps of the met
an S & B power struggle we did a lot of
met steps that's like a kind of like
iconic
Gossip Girl in a first joint interview
of the couple also joked about their
Gossip Girl and OC teenage dream
marriage do is embrace the fact that
Seth and Blair ended up together
you guys ever laugh about that
occasionally yeah maybe occasionally
yeah once again we have a second Blair
day it's exciting to us for laughs it's
good for a laugh
[Music]
you